michael is there anything you need from
me i'd like to go back to bed
yeah joe just get some rest to see you
monday unless you're still sick
um all right we'll have a great long
weekend i'll probably be just sweet
you enjoyed that didn't you
have kids and i'm going to get married
not necessarily in that order
and they are going to live here what
i love you i love you michael i love you
too what are you even talking about
i was just talking about i farted
are you kidding me i did oh my god
this is this is my place okay
let's go back to one hello michael how
are you
good how are you good to see you oh
sorry there
okay well why don't we just step in what
[Laughter]
he'd enjoy to be fired i don't think he
would tell him really that i am far
too valuable to you
fire who
i i what who is he saying
i can't really make it out it's fired
wyatt you you know what those are
grounds
michael look at that
[Music]
hey jim hey what's up hey
um i know it's last minute but
i was wondering
[Music]
hey hey um
i know it's last minute but i was
wondering if it would be
no that was you i was wondering if it
would be cool
i didn't do anything i was wondering if
it would be
cool if i brought my oh my god wait
it's casual so i'm not really worried
about numbers or anything cool all right
thanks nobody even signed my birthday
poster probably because it doesn't even
look like me
it's from last year no
[Laughter]
you're making it work
so see i will end up having your butt in
jail and what they will do to you
is nothing compared to what i'll do to
you before you get down there
you are not to be ready
he said i was dull
i'm not
he said i was dull
i am hoping to find whoever committed
this heinous deed
and i am praying that i find this
heinous culprit
i will pray to thor himself
[Laughter]
i'm not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am praying to find the heinous culprit
i am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this anus crime
i am praying to finally
i'm not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am praying
[Laughter]
i am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime
i am praying to find this heinous
culprit
and i will pray
i'm sorry i'm not
okay i can do it
excuse me
we try that again
no it's about my work situation and my
living situation and how they coalesce
into one another
because i need a living situation in
order to do my job what
please
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
please
[Laughter]
stanley howard bob vance vance
refrigeration
ryan howard dance dance refrigeration
it's my dad yeah hi um
when should we bring out the cake 1 or 1
30. one's good
1 30.
i'm sorry are we boring you not phyllis
i see the sales department are down
there they're in the engine room and
they are shoveling coal into the furnace
right i mean who saw the movie titanic
they were very important in the movie
titanic
everyone in the engine room drowned okay
[Laughter]
your ass is on the line mister so is
mine
now i'm going to ask you again what time
did you go home last night
um six six
of course
something funny because you know what
millions of people die every year from
drug use
marijuana leads to crack which leads to
crystal meth
which leads to death which leads
me i wanna give
you a nappy head because you're leslie
well that's not your character
where is the clitoris
if someone says next to the vagina
does that mean
on the leg
[Laughter]
what does the female vagina look like
really
sorry um my uncle told me
it looked like a sausage casing
i can't work with this
it's too loud what oh we're too loud
there anyway
i don't know why i did this
suddenly clearly a different character
literally a whole different guy
it's too loud i can't hear you it's too
loud we're almost there
even though this is a cul-de-sac
i missed my left
knock it off i'm connecting this
interview no that's not what you said
when i came in here you said that i was
conducting the interview now exactly how
much pot did you smoke
uh i want
chili's baby back ribs
[Laughter]
i want my baby back baby
chili's baby back ribs
no wait out the second one okay
[Laughter]
i look forward to drug testing i used to
get a runner's high
which is why now i lift
i look forward to drug testing but
urinating is not something
this is not a joke this is not a
carnival
kind of
what it is nice job nice work
this is busiest beaver i know it says
busiest
no no you screwed that up didn't you i
guess we have to go back don't we
we're wasting a lot of tape give me that
okay listen
you